franchement
pour jean louis bricout députés du parti
socialiste de l'aisne les divergences
entre les partis de gauche sont trop
importantes pour se rassembler écoutez
écoutez moi je déjà bon cette primaire
populaire
qui part d'une bonne intention parce que
l'attention c'est quand même de
rassembler rassembler à gauche le
problème c'est que quand on regarde un
peu épisode paysage politique à gauche
on a toute une frange qui va je veux
dire de deux du centre gauche jusqu'aux
extrêmes des taux des progressistes la
social-démocratie quelque part puis
après une gauche les plus extrêmes pour
moi les deux sont quelque part à
conciliables est-ce qu'on n'est pas sur
le même politique et puis c'est donc
déjà ça me paraît difficile de
rassembler tout le monde sous cette même
bannière moi ça me paraît quand même
très compliqué alors année anne hidalgo
c'est vrai que les positions sont un peu
changeantes sont pas forcément toujours
en face entre le parti bureau national
et la candidate sur cette première
populaire
moi je le déplore parce qu'en fin de
compte c'est l'objectif c'était un
rassemblement on arrive à diviser ce
rassemblement donc c'est quand même ça
devient compliqué quand même hein c'est
fr et dans